[Music]
order
going home before we go
I confess I killed you look I killed
anyone's interest in seeing you critic
are you okay
yeah what about target practice at Raja
Gosnell house o matic if you don't open
the door we're gonna drink all the ecto
cooler and leave nothing for you I
thought we're gonna do that anyway oh he
doesn't know that oh my god
when he's a 9-millimeter let's kick back
thank you oh thank god he was saying the
strangest things about a movie that
everyone hates clearly his soul has been
twisted by the devil do not worry if
there's one thing I know there's how to
force the Internet's opinion with shame
it's just good to know that he has such
good friends this there's no chance of
him as far welcome oh sorry I'm gonna do
something do it right
should be proud of me leave me alone
your friends told me you were saying
some concerning things about a movie
it's okay all terrible movies are
equally bad in the eyes of the Internet
are they tell me how well-trained are
you embed film adaptations I know a
little bigger films mostly aha then you
must know why a dr. Seuss character
sticking his head in a woman's cleavage
and having a man kiss a dog's ass
doesn't work I can't say that I do
isn't that the beloved adaptation of The
Grinch oh Christ all right well surely
must know why the Mad Hatter
breakdancing and applying rules and
logic to an illogical world that can't
even represent the title right doesn't
work I regret it is not too familiar it
does sound like that smash hit Alice in
Wonderland though
here what about this one an animated
Muhsin squirrel trying to save the world
from a villain with a lame accent they
make all sorts of forced puns with
slappy slapstick and no story yes I know
that I'm sorry I had no idea you
despised that film as much as everyone
else
I didn't that was Rocky and Bullwinkle
the film you accused yourself of killing
you heard that for God's sake my son if
you have something to confess do it now
they were my icons Rocky and Bullwinkle
the popular TV show that ran from 1959
to 1964 while kids could enjoy the
adventures of a cynical squirrel and a
brain-dead mousse escaping the clutches
of Boris Natasha and fearless leader
adults enjoyed a ton of in jokes and
smart writing that would usually go over
most children's heads it was one of the
first animated TV shows where the focus
was more on the humour for grownups and
less on exciting stories for kids
resulting in some brilliant puns you
went to college
Penn State State and some nutso
brilliant puns it's from Washington
Washington Busey her die with a Lincoln
fan there was no doubt it was corny but
still clever
it showed caring little about the
scenario could actually be funny itself
if you used it with the right kind of
comedy but nevertheless when the movie
was advertised years later people
shuddered and discussed these were
clearly some of the worst trailers ever
released since any of the trailers in
there's like he was one of my length
learning D they were bad really really
bad as I read countless requests upon
countless requests I finally decided to
watch this sack of moose droppings as I
put the DVD in to review it I played a
little game with myself the internet
despised this movie critics gave it a 43
percent on Rotten Tomatoes did it show
did even the first couple minutes
represent how awful this adaptation was
I pushed play on the remote and started
to watch Rocky and Bullwinkle themselves
were forced to subsist on ever
diminishing residual checks from reruns
of their old job but something strange
started to happen to me something I
didn't think would happen to me after
all the hatred and awful advertisements
I started to laugh the plans were
crushed and a part of the iron that was
Rocky and Bullwinkle that that clearly
well-written faithful adaptation being
shown to be on the screen while the
narrator that's named force to move in
with his mother where he was reduced to
narrating the offense of his own life it
seemed to have the same spirit the same
humor even kind of a similar animation
style no no no no this has to be a
mistake it must be it's better Pierre I
just want to clarify you tried to kill
yourself over this move the movie
continued explaining how Rocky and
Bullwinkle we're trapped in reruns and
their home in the forest been chopped
out I'm the chairman of the prospect for
fatality for wildlife conversation you
mean wildlife conservation you
somebody's gonna start talking about
these things even their wordplay had
become hackneyed and cheap no it was
always like these wow they even
acknowledge how forced a lot of their
humor can be I I'm legitimately confused
this seems like the typical Rocky and
Bullwinkle writing maybe even a little
better because of its awareness of how
it's being perceived like surely
something has to throw this all off
five action of course now we're going to
Brendan Fraser Brad Pitt and Robert
DeNiro this up oh wait this was the one
he wasn't even better we see how Janeane
Garofalo chooses her movie scripts Joe
intelligent when Boris Natasha and
fearless leader convince her that they
should make a rocky and bullwinkle movie
what is it is classic American kind of
doing from early 60s and as you know
films based on shows from the 60s always
equal cinematic success so she signs the
contract bringing them into the real
world so now we have DeNiro as fearless
leader Jason Alexander is Boris everyday
Russo as Natasha how did that happen we
are attached to the project was that
your excuse for Little Fockers but the
studio president Carl Reiner says he
don't like moose pictures I don't like
moose pictures a very specific prejudice
but the evil trio put out rbtv
really bad television to hypnotize the
world through awful shows to do whatever
they want oh that explains I think
everything but the FBI director Randy
Quaid I'm back from Canada he's putting
his top agent on the case Karen sympathy
played by Piper Perabo looper that
that's where you know her from she's so
idealistic warm-hearted and beautiful
she can't help but smile when she's
called idealistic warm-hearted and
beautiful idealistic warm-hearted and
beautiful FBI agent Karen sympathy damn
it this movie's charming I want to kiss
me and carry me off to a castle give me
something to work with are you familiar
with the Rocky and Bullwinkle show Oh
I mean mmm
I've heard of it okay that was
Nickelodeon TV movie awkward we're back
on track all that's missing is a visual
gauge even haunted house when use it's
almost as if there were a mole in the
White House
I just ridiculous yes this I can work
with in that it doesn't work which
worked for me I've a weird job so she
sneaks into the studio to try and bring
Rocky and Bullwinkle to life by
literally choosing the genre of the
movie they're about to star in and using
literally a green light to create them
this is so meta even the Muppets would
turn to the camera and say you know I'm
just a bunch of foam with a puppeteer
attached to me right I don't even know
how many more fourth walls we can break
but it works and our two heroes are set
free rocky Bullwinkle it's such a
pleasure to meet the only reason Dave
Coulier got a job on full house
something you'll notice very quickly is
that the animation on the two of them is
clearly computer-generated you would
think that this would make them seem
less well anime and more solid and slow
but in a strange way it actually works
Rocky and Bullwinkle didn't exist in a
world of motion it was mainly an excuse
to make verbal jokes so in this
environment nothing is really lost if
anything it really kind of looks like
they're in the scene interacting with
people despite them obviously being
cartoons it's not as good as say Roger
Rabbit but it is better than other
movies where clearly they never look
like they occupy the same space the CG
surprisingly really fits now if only
that's somehow up to Rocky's prozac
prescription wait a minute why don't we
take an airplane it's just not boy I
could fly if I head to we're supposed to
be the heel I guess the world just
doesn't need us I swear every time he's
on screen he's always bitching or moping
about something that's not what you said
be cool
Bullwinkle that's not what you mean what
network are you from what's the boy know
even your would be like Christ I rather
be thrown in a fire with a vomiting rat
don't listen to this guy
so they outrun the police because
clearly the FBI can ask to do any of
this and they make it tour car did you
watch your show did I watch your show I
loved your show yeah did I'm a beautiful
lipgloss wearing 19 year old woman of
course I've seen Rocky and Bullwinkle I
look just like the rest of our
demographic we also see Bullwinkle's
antlers can intercept radio frequencies
no I'm just getting jiggy with it don't
they know every time a movie makes that
reference God's finger gets a little
closer to smoting us kind of just
getting jiggy with it some the villains
begin their hypnotizing test to see if
they can make people dark way to
actually destroy a cartoon character
until now what about little movie Roger
Rabbit shut up it's totally step right
no that was funny it was a funny line
funny delivery even then awkward silence
kind of made it work again it really is
like Rocky and Bullwinkle some of the
jokes are funny and some of the jokes
are awful that's always what they were
yes all that's missing all the confusing
jokes the ones that don't make sense as
a kid or an adult Oh like I don't know
having an unexplained kid as an evil
scientist yes that would be mad a
confused computer degenerating imagery
or CD eyes I like to call it wha that's
his artist a random animated weasel they
just found now I know what happened I've
been ready the ferret oh no it's okay
before you even get a chance to question
it they throw in a funny line so you
completely forgot what you were confused
about centum we're all worthless severed
Junkins
I feel delighted annoyed and puzzled all
at the same time exactly that was rocky
and bullwinkle
what was the movie up to could it be so
clever that it was purposefully bad in
some places and purposefully odd in
others no no it has to just be bad this
is 2016 Internet and I will not allow
anything down the middle especially for
the feature oh I don't know this sound
effects becoming pretty annoying okay
that is entirely bad but insight
fearless leaders I there's a cartoon
because the director said they'll get it
when suddenly objects start falling from
the sky wow you are the one driving
beware me thank you me they get away
though leaving boris and Natasha to face
the punishment of Robert De Niro's
in-joke are you talking to me are you
talking to me and when I say in I mean
about is in is John Travolta or Tom
Cruise it's so naughty and that it's
pretty much out the two of them steal a
helicopter from a very strange Jonathan
winters cameo sick and tired of shopping
for a helicopter I pull your buns right
out of the sky Oh leave that alone he
was very old and said yes to two of
these for God's sake but our heroes get
intercepted by a possibly stranger cameo
from John Goodman but she really is with
the FBI yeah and I'm really John Goodman
let's get in the car
you know after Blues Brothers 2000 I
went in that I was John Goodman either
so they're separated from the coyote
ugly co-star yes that's the other one
you know we're from put it down as I
partake in what a shock more puns we
don't have time to get to Washington
this is no time to worry about getting
the walking done you know rocky and
bullwinkle really need a pawn scale
something to show which ones
legitimately work and which ones are
Hitler's ass scratchers
movies getting kinda don't say it
two-dimensional fun will go something's
watching rocky and bullwinkle again the
picked up however by a dual love hey
this was a thing see we guys been all
this time yeah reruns no that's never
gonna happen us right boy
I don't know whether to feel bad or no
that's the only option they go to the
boys college which was actually a school
Bullwinkle went to in the show but
there's just one problem
the college is anti moose what is with
all the routine in this what did he
violate your safe space with his giant
antlers is he now on the wall of
entertainers there too shocking to
perform at colleges speaking of which
Karen flirts with a Swedish guard by
promising to take him to the movies if
he gets her out but is it me or her hand
gestures a little too um symbolic how
would we eat her popcorn well we could
eat our popcorn with one hand and hold
hands with the other thank God
Bullwinkle wasn't firing the puns on
this one bully she really knows how to
squeeze my hose Oh rankle Angela sing
she really knows how to make the wit
stuff come out Bullwinkle oh and with
icy come up okay
don't come crying to me if the FCC
leaves a horse head on your mattress at
least I wouldn't be the only one getting
hit oh Christ
back at the college rocky sees Boris is
about to attack so he tries once more to
see if he can remember how to fly
luckily rocky had delicious Taco Bell
Taco but he files their evil plan saves
Bullwinkle yet somehow still finds
something to be upset about yes I've
lost the night I'll never fly you dude
seriously so locked prozac that creepy
from we happy few take something
you depress win shock yes political
speech was so lame that the students
couldn't understand a word he was saying
and consequently found nothing to
objective oh my god this movie mayor
predicted the future now they don't find
something to objective
plus there are some legitimately funny
scenes like the nice Swedish guard who
helps KarenT escape to go to the movies
she totally abandons him doesn't even
think twice
honestly this movie really does have a
lot of the characteristics of the
original cartoon right down to some of
it being brilliant and some of it being
painful I'm sorry but it really is a
good adaptation but why this film why is
rocky and bullwinkle the adaptation that
works with all the great cartoons turned
into live-action why is this the
one that gets all the effort even down
to the flaws
these other adaptations deserve better
what are you saying
I'm saying from now on the movie and I
are enemies because it chooses this
piece of crap to represent perfectly
when other adaptations deserve the
attention because it is unjust
fare unkind I will plug it I swear it
I will hinder and harm that feature on
earth as I am able I will ruin and
squirrel
you know people already hate it right
well yeah
but I'll make them hate it even more
that's not very impressed you're never
you Chris
you
so whacking bullwinkle raised toward
Chicago probably lured by they're
filming tax breaks it wouldn't last
where they drive through to Italian
peasants just so they can crash through
some fruit cards in their chase if
that's not funny enough get a load of
this weird silent moment I have no idea
why that was there but it just cracks me
up
what's this supposed to be an
out-of-body experience like we're
supposed to hear their thoughts I never
did tell her how I really feel you know
would be pointless right now a big
crystal can you oh that's a sauce
mattress this cameo just fixed my pipes
in my summer home yeah a lot of the
cameos in this movie if you haven't
noticed don't really make a lot of sense
it's the equivalent of using an
unpopular appearance twice for no real
reason we just saw Jonathan winters why
are they using him again oh and it
doesn't tie into any joke it's not like
that's his brother or his look-alike or
the same person it's just Jonathan
winters as a different character oh why
not complete the trilogy in heaven
pop-up has another completely different
character I'm high I am completely high
why would there be three Jonathan Winter
cameos what was this in his contract he
had to play more than one character no
matter how brief or pointless what if
you have that same contract in Smurfs
hey everybody do you like my new dress I
got you now Papa Smurf
meow he doesn't always have to be a
one-man everything our heroes escape the
villains again which just curls
Alexander's reverse Hitler stache but
Karen tries to encourage rocky to
conquer his fear of fly high I feel like
we've done this already
[Music]
this is the most exciting moment since
let's look at the clock here 20 minutes
ago
20 minutes ago is when this happened I
was just as excited that actually no I'm
less excited because we did it what was
it again 20 minutes ago we come across
this image that quite frankly I have no
words for at the villains lie about
destroying our heroes making fearless
leader very happy excellent my food is
excellent go home movie you're drunk
I clearly had them licked enough toads
for this how is it Robert De Niro has
been in movies where he's worn fake
boobs and yet somehow this seems more
demeaning well at least they get
chocolates though I've so many questions
Karen and rocky get captured and see
what fearless leader has done to the
other agents
and now ladies and gentlemen the main
cause of your bedwetting tonight look
close look close and deep there's no way
you're getting those urine stains out of
your mattress not terrifying enough what
if we meld it with a beautiful lady in
one of your cartoon icons rule 34 has
nothing on this insanity the Lord knows
someone's jerking off to it meanwhile
Bullwinkle accidentally lands in
Washington well as long as a year ladies
we'll talk to the president about three
oh yeah
the trees are still a thing is this like
a last-minute environmental message
because it's not worked in very well I
don't think Gone with the Wind would be
very powerful if they suddenly threw in
wares like a what I do frankly my hair I
don't give a damn and by the way don't
smoke
buck Wade is still there and realizes
the best way to get Bullwinkle to save
them is to email him over silly
what's this site called tentacle hint
i7c
I'm virtually still at our BTB
no not really we just want to show off
we could do that effect but it's too
late for everyone is under fearless
leaders control and he forces the world
to vote for him what foolish leader we
either one works in this scenario but
bowinkle's antlers reverse the signal
and he slams into De Niro surprisingly
holding back a Raging Bull joke I would
have done it I would have done it
everything gets wrapped up and our
heroes of course save the day and our
bpv changed its name from really fat
television directly and Bullwinkle
television what stripping Wow I think
Rocky's negativity is really rubbing off
on him y'all gon learn how to love
yourselves speaking of which Charon is
allowed to love her inner child because
the film reminds us that was a thing and
she even goes back to the Swedish guy
who is still waiting at the movies the
whole time ah dammit that's funny I
don't care if he looks like James
Marsden melted into Greg Sestero
it's still a funny joke the trees are
planted again until the next
computer-generated jackass complains
about them and all is right with the
world
except for the fact that it's here it's
here on nostalgia critic and you know
what that means destruction destruction
of the feature done by the destroyer of
films nostalgia critic
what passion what comedy
he has been touched by the internet gods
and Hollywood Moors to listen Hollywood
that decided this was going to be one of
the most faithful adaptations while
other adaptations desert but I for once
Indian laughing at them still I have to
admit I kind of liked it
okay it's nothing great but Rocky and
Bullwinkle wasn't really anything great
either it could be brilliant but it
could also be kind of life it could be
creative but it could also kind of be
phoned in the jokes overshadowed the
story and characters every time but that
was always the idea and that's precisely
what this film is it captures its source
material to a tee even the trailer
redubbed a lot of the lines so it would
sound lamer for some reason with ripping
so it's no wonder nobody wanted to see
it it has a similar feel as Georgia the
jungle it's obviously meant to be a kids
movie with some tongue-in-cheek jokes
for adults but it never loses track that
it's mainly just meant for kids yeah I
guess for the most part and as kids
films go this is fine no classic or
anything but that's solid C c plus if
you're not a fan the original cartoon
you probably won't be a fan here hope
you have a soft spot for puns good or
bad fourth-wall jokes and kind of an
awkward yet still likable charm god help
me I actually think this is enjoyable
enough to watch
[Music]
are you surprised by my choice my
ability to disagree with the masses my
balls eNOS to enjoy something so
universally despised oh boy you really
can't talk a man's ear off so you really
liked rock-a-doodle get out of here okay
oh and tell the others that enjoy
mediocrity that I will speak for them I
am their champion has he gone crazy I
think the real question is was he ever
safe yogurty ideologies everywhere I
fight you all okay you okay you're okay
all you mediocrities are okay you are
[Music]
you
Oh